tu ne sais pas prendre les décisions en
fait tu veux que je te dise un mytho
parce que tout ça
[Applaudissements]
rescapés de cette maison de l'horreur
Bryan qui a porté plainte contre ses
parents était venu sur notre plateau
pour raconter le calvaire qu'il a vécu
avec ses frères et sœurs sa tante mais
aussi d'autres proches ont finalement
décidé de confirmer sa version des faits
dans un reportage explosif diffusé hier
soir dans 7 à 8 chez les enfants qui
faisaient tout le temps
ils ont réussi à le joindre dans le
reportage ton père au téléphone et on va
écouter les propos de votre père vous
allez réagir de se regarder
non plus on a même dit que vos enfants
étaient attachés ça c'est vrai ou pas
je m'attendais pas à ce qui est ce qui
assume d'aussitôt il dit que qu'il
y'attache la petite puisque elle est
malade mais il y en a peut-être une
deuxième qui est pas du tout malade qui
est normalement bah elle est pas en
parfaite santé comme elle a attaché 23
elle était attachée 3 heures sur 24 mais
elle n'était pas malade la petite ne
tombez pas ça c'est tout simplement
d'excuses d'accord Rudy toi tu as vécu
des moments très très compliqués ce que
nous a dit ton frère Bryan il y a
quelque chose qui a posé un énorme
problème à ton père enfin j'ai
l'impression que tout lui poser problème
et qu'il a rendu encore plus violent
avec toi c'est le fait que tu sois
homosexuel et que tu lui dis là il
paraît qu'il s'est avec ton nom qui
c'est voilà c'était des déchaînements de
de haine
exactement
en fait les violences j'ai subi déjà
avant
mon coming out pour toi il y a toujours
eu de la maltraitance il y a pas une
seule fois où
je n'aime jamais il nous a jamais pris
dans ses bras il nous a jamais dit vous
êtes mes enfants je vous aime c'est
seuls affections entre parenthèses si je
peux dire c'était les cookies nous
donner ah mais 18 ans c'était la goutte
de trop je devais aller à ce moment-là
j'utilise j'étais en couple avec un
garçon d'accord et qui m'empêcher de
voir sauf qu'à un moment donné j'en ai
marre c'était je voulais un peu être
libre en fait vous voulez pas c'est pas
grave moi maintenant je prends mes
affaires et je pars une fois parti je me
sentais si bien c'était le seul moment
de ma vie ou en pensant à eux je me sens
bien parce que je n'étais plus avec eux
quand tu as vu que l'affaire avec la
tête qu'est-ce que tu t'es dit je me
suis dit là moi les gens vont peut-être
agir on pense à nous on pense à mes
frères et soeurs mais on pense aussi
peut-être au futur ou aux aussi qui
subissent Magali merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes la tente maternelle des
enfants je voyais la maison salle
ça je pourrais pas nier personnellement
car plus d'une fois en fait en allant
là-bas le nombre des fois où j'ai
proposé mon aide en lui disant tu veux
de l'aide pour la maison tu veux de
l'aide pour les enfants ça a toujours
été déçu je lui ai proposé de prendre
l'une des petites à la maison pour
dormir la nuit ça a été un refus
également comment vivaient les enfants
quand vous alliez là-bas vous voyez
qu'il y avait un problème qui était
malheureux ils ont essayé de vous parler
à un moment ou pas
j'aurais aimé justement qui viennent
nous voir quand j'arrivais les petites
étaient changées attachés mais voilà
attaché vous me dit bah elle regarde
juste un dessin animé ouais elles font
juste la sieste
où dorment les petites elle m'a juré en
me regardant droit dans les yeux elle
dort dans leur lit
c'est ma nièce qui deux jours plus tard
m'a appelé en larmes Matuidi elle dort
attaché dans les chaises elle dort dans
leurs excréments et là franchement on
sent il a bouillie tout de suite j'ai
fait dans ce pas possible je fais non
c'est hors de question que je laisserai
ça souffert donc les petites sont
placées pour leur sécurité c'est une
horreur de faire ça c'est des enfants le
mot est encore trop faible à mes yeux
vous vivez en enfer depuis
qu'est ce qui s'est passé pareil que
vous avez même été agressé j'ai été
agressé effectivement je finissais à 16h
ce jour-là c'était mercredi dernier je
finissais à 16h et je réentamé le soir
pour 10 à 18h donc pour moi j'avais deux
heures de battement je me suis dit je
vais aller juste au magasin me chercher
un petit café glacé donc je rentre dans
le magasin et déjà je ressens des
regards c'est possible et je me suis dit
bon c'est pas grave OK et en fait arrivé
sur le parking j'ai entendu derrière moi
une personne hurlé
on se retrouvera excusez-moi des mots on
se retrouvera grosse [ __ ] on sera à
plusieurs mais on va te crever est-ce
que vous allez reparler à votre sœur
est-ce que vous allez essayer de la
raisonner ou est-ce que vous allez
couper complètement avec elle je coupe
complètement les fonds
de parler d'elle clairement ce n'est
plus la peine qu'elle vous m'envoie un
message j'ai reçu un message d'elle il y
a deux jours en me disant qu'elle était
désolée pour mon agression
que elle ne comprenait pas et qu'elle
m'aimait
mais non c'est pas à moi que tu dois des
excuses oui je vis un enfer mais tes
enfants vécu un enfer bien pire que le
mien
franchement et c'est à eux que tu dois
t'excuser pas auprès de moi
on a on apprend un peu plus derrière sur
la rémunération d'une des stars de
télé-réalité mais là Jasmine qui
totalise plus de 3,2 millions followers
elle n'hésite pas à avouer face caméra
les hommes astronomiques qu'elle gagne
voilà on va voir cet extrait qui a fait
énormément parlé on va voir les
plusieurs extraits qui font qu'on fait
parler il y a des mois où on
[Musique]
c'est pas que c'est pas c'est pas tabou
pour moi mais mais oui je suis
millionnaire je sais que comme vous
dites c'est les téléspectateurs en fait
de on a vraiment voulu révéler cet
écosystème cette galaxie ces personnes
et en fait c'est les réseaux sociaux oui
nous on connaît et oui sociaux mais il y
en a plein de gens je pense que après je
veux pas non plus avoir un jugement sur
les téléspectateurs de compléments
d'enquête mais je pense qu'on leur a
révélé beaucoup de choses et ce que
leurs enfants regardent oui
l'agence à elle aussi été rachetée par
un grand groupe satisfaction dirigé par
l'animateur Arthur qui produit les Anges
de la télé-réalité ou la Villa des cœurs
brisés une fois le contrat signé Cindy
touche 100 euros par vidéo où elle place
des produits comme ces shampoings vendus
plus de 30 euros le flacon et en fait au
bout d'une semaine d'utilisation j'ai
déjà des cheveux qui commencent à
changer et dès que je sors de la douche
que je me coiffe
c'est des poignées de cheveux qui
commencent à tomber en fait que Cindy
est obligé de se raser la tête regarder
après d'avoir utilisé ses shampoings
c'en est trop possible
[Musique]
quant à ses cheveux elle opte pour une
solution radicale qu'elle a bien sûr
mise en ligne sur ses réseaux ça c'est à
dire le chat parce que pour une femme
c'est un choc de devoir se réaliser la
tête viens de me voir comme ça les
cheveux rasés ça a été ça a été violent
non c'est très bien d'avoir sensibiliser
le public de France 2 sur les dangers de
l'influence pour les enfants potentiels
c'est bien aussi d'avoir montré qu'il y
a plusieurs agences qui sont concernées
et là ce qui est doublement grave c'est
que non seulement c'est cette agence
donc l'agence de WC qui propose ça mais
en plus c'est sa marque c'est lui qui
produit ses propres shampoings en
l'occurrence qui sont dangereux pour la
santé et ça je trouve que vous l'avez
bien révélé vous l'avez pas épargné pour
le coup donc ça pour le coup l'enquête
était bien faite c'est un placement de
produit une marque de maillot de bain
paye Nina pour cette publication et
plutôt bien on est rémunéré entre 1500
et 3000 euros le titre un business qui
marche tu es content de travailler ce
que tout ce que tu fais ça vient pour
toi et tu donnes rien aux autres et ça
te motive encore plus le matin tu as la
harpe quoi
les influenceurs au début il vous donne
énormément ensuite il réfléchissent et
puis ils ont peur pourquoi parce que il
y a aussi ce tabou de l'argent je pense
en France de dire oui on gagne beaucoup
d'argent ou voilà il y en a qui vivent à
Dubaï et qui paye pas d'impôts ce qui
dérange c'est qui partent à Dubaï il
paye pas d'impôts ici se faire soigner
ou profiter des aides sociales
le dropshipping aujourd'hui ça
représente que 5% de notre chiffre
d'affaires là où l'enquête est moyenne
c'est qu'est-ce que vous pensez de sa
réponse elle dit que topsping c'est 5%
de son chiffre d'affaires vous devriez
pas dire bah je sais pas c'est ce
qu'elle répond si l'enquête est bien
fait vous devrez vous devriez dire non
elle ment on a vérifié c'est plus oui
c'est le bon chiffre c'est là où je
trouve que votre enquête elle est un des
leçons d'enquête aux gens
exploré des dérives et on interview on
interview des personnes qui sont acteurs
de ces dérives donc voilà et donc dans
le film on l'explique bien ce qui se
passe c'est que donc il y a les
histoires donc du dropshipping il y a
les dérivés autour de la chirurgie
esthétique il y a donc énormément de
placements de produits qui qui ne qui ne
sont pas en règle donc les produits
toxiques donc voilà nous on l'a on l'a
expliqué on la relance
c'est le fils de Benjamin Castaldi ça va
faire quatre ans quatre ans
ils attendent un heureux événement donc
je vais devenir tata alors comment il
est avoué
chez H2O il était en stage chez vous non
mais oui
[Rires]
il a fait rentrer il a fait rentrer
c'est Magali bien sûr le bateau et donc
elles sont devenus copains et donc il a
gravi des échos et maintenant il a un
poste de commercial il y a dans les
équipes mais en plus quel est le
problème
ça existe partout dans toutes les
entreprises tu as toujours le fils de
machin qui est embauché en stage parce
que c'est le patron parce que c'est non
mais franchement faut arrêter de tout
s'il était nul
il est viré franchement on s'en fout son
père il est nul aussi il est toujours là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parmi les personnes qui bossent
aujourd'hui on parle d'Amandine
Pélissard candidate de la téléréalité
famille nombreuse l'avion en XXL et si
cette mère de 8 enfants est au cœur de
l'actualité c'est pour l'interview
qu'elle a accordé à Jordan Deluxe où
elle se livre sur sa vie privée
c'est lorsque la jeune femme a déclaré
avoir volé de la nourriture pour ses
enfants lorsqu'elle avait des problèmes
financiers quand on a intégré en
transgresse la loi on transgresse les
règles on a tous malheureusement une
raison de le faire
Amandine a été placé en garde à vue et
risque aujourd'hui six mois de prison
ferme 2016 j'ai malheureusement
volé de la nourriture dans un
supermarché en Franche-Comté où je
vivais à l'époque pour mes enfants
puisque j'étais dans une dans une époque
où la vie était très compliqué pour moi
et pour ma famille mon mari venait de
perdre ton travail en fait l'entreprise
où le travail depuis 10 ans a fermé moi
j'étais en arrêt pathologique parce que
j'étais enceinte avec une menace
d'accouchement prématuré j'ai d'ailleurs
fait une fausse couche j'ai fait une
fausse couche entre eux donc mon
cinquième et mon sixième en fait donc le
problème c'est que on s'est retrouvé du
jour au lendemain avec plus rien
malheureusement il y a des délais
incompressibles quand on se retrouve
ou licencier où on arrêt maladie il y a
des délais et de carence et des délais
administratifs qui ne sont pas
malheureusement
très très pertinent dans le sens où on
se retrouve foncièrement plusieurs
semaines sans rien donc vous avez volé
de la nourriture à l'époque c'était où
c'était quoi c'était en France
en fait j'avais un caddie de course à
roulettes comme plein en ont et je le
remplissais et en fait je passais au
caisses express et je sortais que très
peu de choses
et à quoi vous êtes rattraper je me suis
fait attraper au bout de quelques fois
et quand vous aujourd'hui la justice
vous rattrape sur cette et le problème
c'est que la justice est très longue
donc là l'effet remonte à fin 2016 le
jugement a eu lieu fin 2017 moi j'étais
en train d'accoucher à ce moment là ce
que je n'ai pas trop
détaillé chez Jordan le problème c'est
qu'en fait je n'ai pas été avisé
du jugement parce qu'en fait un huissier
de justice est venu sonner chez moi un
jour sans doute et en fait j'étais jugée
par défaut et donc aujourd'hui vous
risquez quoi alors donc j'ai pris six
mois à faire parce que j'étais une
première fois donc par défaut j'ai fait
opposition à ce jugement
une fois hein
et je n'ai pas été récupéré ma
condamnation enfin mon avis m'a voilà
m'a convocation chez lui c'est de
justice et je pense que ça ça a joué on
m'a défaveur mais l'absence
effectivement c'était notifié d'ailleurs
le fait que vous n'étiez pas à
l'audience à jouer contre vous parce
qu'on a estimé que vous vous dérobiez
oui et donc du coup la peine a été
maximale alors on dirait que je n'ai pas
eu la absolument vous êtes responsable
c'était votre faute entre guillemets
donc on appelle même si à six mois ferme
c'est vrai que ce sera aménagé mais ça
fait frémir 6 mois ferme pour avoir
nourri ses enfants en France
de nourriture
on y voit une feuille d'allocation de
près de euros d'aide accordé à une
famille un montant qui a choqué les
internautes et provoqué une vive
polémique allocation généreuse
transférée de la poche de ceux qui
travaillent du matin au soir vers celles
de ceux qui sont au foyer et au chômage
cette polémique intervient alors que
Fabien Roussel président du Parti
communiste vient de renoncer le débat
sur les allocations sur le site la
gauche doit défendre le travail et ne
pas être la gauche des allocations des
minima sociaux mais je trouve ça
formidable ça c'est la France que j'aime
on est de les gens ouais bravo ça
devient ça devient ridicule on parlait
avant les élections de personnes
effectivement c'est le gros problème des
gens en ce moment à partir du 15 du mois
et je le vois tous mes potes je vous le
jure je le vois avec tous mes potes à
partir du 15 du mois qui sont à 0
net c'est ça
on peut aider les gens sans pour autant
leur servir un plat j'ai cette
hallucinant comme à moi c'est l'inverse
de Mathieu moi je suis exaspéré par ceux
qui mettent oui en fait je trouve c'est
vraiment les analyses niveau bar des
sports c'est à bas les pauvres ils ont
qu'à travailler ils font des enfants
pour les allocations vous connaissez pas
le parcours de vie de cette famille tout
le monde voit alors oui ça choque les
réseaux parce qu'on voit 6000 euros
c'est pas faut enlever 2000 euros donc
c'est une location qui est versée pour
pour la rentrée c'est une famille où il
y a 10 enfants plus de parents il y a 12
personnes donc pardon je pense pas
qu'il mène la vie de château et puis
voilà arrêtez de voir la vie à travers
votre prisme à vous il y a des gens qui
sont pas armés de la même manière qui
ont pas les mêmes parcours de vie
peut-être qu'ils ont des parcours de vie
compliqués et heureusement qu'il y a des
aides sociales en France c'est le
dernier le le dernier avant la rue
d'aide donc heureusement qu'on est dans
un pays qui aide les gens qui sont dans
le besoin et qui n'ont pas la même
chance que tout le monde
tu vois pas 6000 euros avec une
allocation de rentrée sinon c'était pour
12 c'est déjà moins fort alors
maintenant ça reste choquant de 5
millions même si tu enlèves la rentrée
scolaire tu arrives quand même à 3700 €
scolaire donc pour les gens en 3e 700
euros comment tu vas expliquer que eux
un jour ils vont retravailler tu vois
ils vont pas retoucher 3700 euros s'ils
vont travailler donc le système il est
gangrené oui mais après c'est comme on a
dit à un moment donné faut être devant
tes responsabilités si tu fais 10
enfants il faut pouvoir te dire je vais
pouvoir nourrir mes 10 enfants et pas me
servir de l'État et pas me servir de
ceux qui se lèvent le matin et qui vont
bosser et qui vont eux payer des impôts
pour nourrir des gens qui restent à 3700
euros chez eux
c'est-à-dire que là ce que vous êtes en
train de dire c'est [ __ ] de pauvre
[Musique]
tais-toi parce que là ce que tu viens de
dire ça c'est dégueulasse de leur dire
ça c'est dégueulasse que c'est de la
c'est vraiment c'est de la démagogie
c'est nul parce que ils disent non non
c'est nul ce que tu dis c'est nul ce que
tu dis parce que tu veux retourner les
gens et tu veux arrête c'est nul ce que
tu dis c'est pas du tout ce qu'ils ont
dit c'est pourquoi je m'énerve après toi
parce que tu sais que je t'aime beaucoup
mais je pense que tu es vraiment c'est
des gens comme toi qui font
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans la dans la
situation dans laquelle on est tué tu ne
sais pas prendre les décisions tu tu dis
n'importe quoi tu veux faire plaisir à
tout le monde et quand on veut faire
plaisir à tout le monde on fait plaisir
à personne tu n'as pas de règle tu tu tu
vois tu ne sais pas mettre de un cadre
je te jure que c'est vrai et en fait tu
es tu fais de la vieille politique qui
n'a jamais marché et et en fait tu veux
que je te dise un mytho parce que tout
simplement
j'ai une caissière qui gagne 1200 euros
par mois qui travaillent de 8h du matin
à 8h qui est épuisé fatiguant que seul
son enfant qu'est-ce qu'elle fait elle
en fait elle fait rien que le problème
c'est la valorisation du travail les all
c'était l'origine du mouvement des
gilets jaunes des gens qui travaillent
toute la journée
et c'est et ça n'a pas été grandeurs les
mecs les mecs qui bossent ils bossent du
matin au soir comment tu vas expliquer à
ta famille à tes enfants ils disent on
voit papa partir le matin on le voit
rentrer le soir il travaille toute la
journée comment tu vas leur expliquer le
weekend que tu as pas pour aller faire
un cinéma que tabac pour les amener
faire des loisirs comment tu leur
explique ça ils disent pas mais tu
travailles toute la semaine là il faut
des aides pour ces gens-là ça pour moi
ça c'est une urgence je suis désolé Ah
oui combien j'ai eu de potes qui m'ont
dit moi je fais pas de troisième enfant
parce que j'ai pas fait j'ai pas les
moyens de le faire
moi j'ai attendu tard pour faire des
enfants parce que je voulais leur offrir
un cadre de vie un bon cadre de vie on
te dit pas de supprimer les enfants en
cause les aides on les remet pas encore
là
[Musique]
une de ses professeurs l'enseignante a
été blessé à la gorge mais ces jours ne
sont heureusement plus en danger c'était
extrêmement choquant des élèves les
connaissaient a été avec lui au collège
donc à laver et dit que quand on était
au collège j'ai été vraiment très
impulsif quand il s'énervait cassé les
fenêtres au collège etc et cela n'a pas
été signalé au lycée et du coup l'élève
il est rentré dans la salle il avait pas
cours avec la
profit avec personne il y avait aucun
problème il est rentré une d'après ce
qu'on nous a raconté il a rentré une
première fois et il a essayé de la
poignard des fois il a un peu touché au
niveau du cou et après ici il a hésé une
deuxième fois sauf que ça va pas très
bien marché et là du courir et même sur
une photo que tout le monde sait
partager au moment de la sortie il dit
que les gars je vais aller en prison je
sais pas ce qui m'arrive enfin j'ai pas
énervé la prof donc personne ne
comprenait plus ce qui s'est passé après
voilà j'espère que il y a Sandra
elle est en cours avec nous
tranquillement bien sûr on peut pas être
tranquille dans une classe en train
d'apprendre un cours quand un élève on
sait que un élève a essayé de te tuer un
propre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]